there are protests right now
in 20 cities over not over the
redefinition of marriage
not even over the transgender stuff
which is the
next stage of that part of the sexual
Revolution
over Balenciaga
you remember the Balenciaga campaign
we've talked about it on this show and I
keep bringing it up because I don't want
the story to get memory hold Balenciaga
a very very high-end luxury fashion
house
that has celebrity relationships with
every famous person under the sun
certainly all the big prominent Libs who
go to the elite parties they they pushed
advertising campaigns that sexualized
children
little kids in them frowning looking
unhappy holding s m teddy bears and in
another advertising campaign you had the
text to a Supreme Court decision about
child pornography referencing another
Supreme Court decision about child
pornography and that the decision that
it was referencing in that very
meticulously placed court case the
decision was referencing was one which
held the
alleged constitutionality of simulated
child pornography so the whole thing was
super weird you saw satanic references
references to Baal one of the most
prominent demons ever worshiped in in
one of their advertising inmates so the
whole thing was really sick really weird
getting involved sex stuff and kids and
people are rightly Furious about it
so what is happening well Balenciaga is
apologizing Balenciaga
tried to do damage control right away
and this was
a little awkward for the liberals who
reacted to the conservatives observing
this weird sex stuff by saying this is
nothing this is not a big deal you guys
are tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists
what are you talking about and then
Balenciaga goes wipes their social media
networks Instagram all gone other than a
major apology says that they were going
to seek a a lawsuit against the person
who put the photo shoot together so that
really undercut the libs who were saying
this is nothing Burger it's no big deal
but then Balenciaga otherwise was
largely silent about this until now
[Music]
is a Georgian fashion designer he's
currently the creative director for
Balenciaga
super tight with Kim Kardashian he's
collaborated with Kanye West before
Kanye oddly enough during his sort of
performance art presidential campaign
continues to wear Balenciaga clothing
and I think actually defended this guy
demna gavazalia even amid his seemingly
extremely super duper far-right campaign
he's defending Balenciaga
and all these kind of weird liberal
creative types who are pushing the kids
sex stuff which is very very strange but
regardless that's just a little bit of a
footnote but a strange footnote on the
story a demna says
I want to personally apologize for the
wrong artistic choice of concept for the
gifting campaign with the kids and I
take my responsibility it was
inappropriate to have kids promote
objects that had nothing to do with them
the 41 year old posted okay
just want to push back a little here
they were holding teddy bears
so
the teddy bears happened to be wrapped
up in this weird S M Leather sex stuff
but you can't say that the object they
were holding had nothing to do with them
the object they were holding was a teddy
bear which has a lot to do with little
kids
part of what's so creepy here is not
just that there were kids in the ad
the kids were holding a a kid object
that had been sexualized
it's weird that the the kids were in the
ad at all but the just the fact that a
little teddy bear was being so
sexualized that is also weird so that's
already making me think hold on wait
what you're you want to apologize
for the artistic choice of concept but
now yeah it doesn't seem like you're
being totally honest if you're saying an
s m teddy bear has nothing to do with
kids he says as much as I would
sometimes like to provoke a thought
through my work I would never have an
intention to do that with such an awful
subject as child abuse that I condemn
period
now this is another another little weird
thing I just noticed this now in the in
the way the sentence is written
he says I would never do it with such an
awful subject as child abuse that I
condemn he doesn't say I would never do
it with child abuse comma which I
condemn which would say I condemn child
abuse per se it's he says I would never
engage with an awful subject as child
abuse that I condemn the difference
being that because he's not condemning
child abuse is a category there might be
some kind of child abuse that he does
not condemn
it would be like saying I'd hold up a
blue m m and I say these are the M Ms
that I love
I love the blue M M's The Other M M's
the jury is at or I could say these are
the M Ms which I love that would that
would say I love these M M's is demna
Gabba zalia thinking that deeply about
the syntax here I'm not so sure but it
that is just kind of weird taken in the
context of the whole statement because
he then he goes on he says I need to
learn from this listen and engage with
child protection organizations to know
how I can contribute and help on this
terrible subject I apologize to anyone
offended by the visuals and Balenciaga
has guaranteed that adequate measures
will be taken not only to avoid similar
mistakes in the future but also to take
accountability in protecting child
welfare in every way we can again here
you see kind of a fake apology
I apologize to anyone offended by
that's that's
the the lamest kind of apology you can
make
when when you say hey I'm sorry if you
were offended by what I said no that's
not an apology you can't apologize for
the way someone feels you can only
apologize for your own actions
so you can say I apologize that I put
this together
I apologize that I did a thing that is
offensive
we didn't say that apologize to anyone
offended
and I guarantee uh we'll take steps to
protect this in the future and then in
conjunction with this announcement
Balenciaga said that it would drop its
25 million dollar lawsuit against the
marketing agency North six which put
this together
uh
shows you that Balenciaga bore much more
responsibility for the campaign than
they wanted to admit
why are they dropping the lawsuit
they're dropping the lawsuit because it
wasn't just some random marketing
campaign that they hired that went off
on their own and and did this crazy
thing that Balenciaga condemns they're
dropping the lawsuit because they know
that Balenciaga was itself involved in
the campaign
and they're dropping the lawsuit because
balenciaga's creative director is saying
yeah I had an artistic vision and that
wasn't great
that's why they're doing it if
Balenciaga really thought they could get
25 million dollars from this marketing
firm North six they would do it but
Balenciaga is not going to bring the
lawsuit why because they don't want to
go through Discovery and because they
think that they're going to lose the
case
and now Balenciaga says we're gonna
we're gonna donate instead to
organizations focused on protecting
children
oh yeah and also this whole apology
comes two weeks after the fact
two weeks after the fact because the the
controversy hasn't died down because
there are protests in 20 cities I would
not try I do not accept this apology I
do not believe this apology I think this
is Crisis Communications major damage
control it does not seem sincere to me
at all and it seems like there is a lot
more going on behind the scenes at
Balenciaga and I think people should
keep pulling on that thread because
every every single day it seems we learn
something new about what's going on
behind the scenes there and it's really
weird and creepy and freaky and we
should figure it out the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]